arrivez-vous à ne plus penser à votre
travail en dehors de l'établissement
envisagez-vous de quitter l'hôpital où
êtes-vous physiquement épuisé voilà
quelques unes des questions posées aux
agents qui exercent à l'hôpital de
Chinon une enquête du syndicat FO
réalisé en avril dernier pour évaluer le
niveau d'épuisement du personnel
décryptage des 532 réponses et analyse
d'un mal-être sous-jacent avec Faustine
Luneau
le syndicat FO à sonder le personnel et
le bilan n'est pas rose au total 532
agents du centre hospitalier de Chinon
soit plus de la moitié ont répandu à une
enquête sur leurs qualités de vie au
travail le résultat qui en ressort plus
de 50% du personnel présenteraient des
signes manifestes de Burnout
professionnel on s'attendait à ses
résultats puisqu'on a pu palper la
souffrance des agents au quotidien quand
on fait des tours dans les services
qu'on va recueillir leurs sentiments
après que le résultat soit si noir et si
alarmant on espérait pas
tous les services et les corps de
métiers sont concernés de manière plus
ou moins avancée mais ce sont ceux qui
ont le plus d'ancienneté et travaillant
dans les métiers les plus précaires
comme les aides-soignants par exemple
qui sont le plus touchés en particulier
en gériatrie qu'est-ce que vous demandez
du coup maintenant des moyens c'est à
dire avoir du personnel qu'on arrête de
supprimer des effectifs l'année dernière
on est quand même en grève depuis un an
concernant du coup la baisse des
effectifs et voilà aujourd'hui le
résultat on se demande si c'est pas de
la compétence ou une volonté détruire
l'hôpital de Chinon parce que pour en
arriver un tel constat de d'avoir fermé
122 lits en un temps sur 664 c'est quand
même assez grave contactez la direction
dénonce des questions orientées et une
enquête uniquement à charge qui
n'évaluerait pas la qualité de vie au
travail le syndicat est faux lui a
déposé un préavis de grève et appelle à
manifester le 6 juin pour dénoncer les
conditions de travail de l'hôpital de
Chinon